this question you raise about why women
encouraging each other to do it you're
right i mean one exception i give do you
have a friend who went on a date with a
guy who said you're so hot you should be
on only fans
and she did not go on a date with him
again because it was just so obviously i
know failing strategy i think yeah
because
the way that she interpreted it and i
think correctly was that he was
he was clearly not regarding her as like
wife material right and this is this is
i think an area that women do make
sometimes where they don't have a good
understanding of male sexuality and they
don't
it's really interesting i don't know if
you read david buss's book bad men oh
yeah absolutely yeah i brought him on
for the show
yeah and he talks about the fact that
women tend to assess like short-term
partners and long-term partners based on
the same
qualities they want the same things in
all the men they have sex with
men don't do that they have a much lower
standard for their short-term partners
and they do for long-term partners and
so they will be willing to have sex with
a woman that they absolutely would not
marry they would not even introduce to
their friends
and i think a lot of women don't
necessarily know that and so they will
interpret sexual
advances from men as flattering
when actually they are potentially like
cheap you know this is the genesis of
the alpha widow right like this is what
many girls that are liberated sexually
and using tinder and stuff like that
don't get and i think that this is
another i'm i'm actually not so
convinced about quite how big of an of
an effect this is i'd need to see rob go
and do some research about it but
certainly women are able to sleep with
men that they wouldn't be able to get
into a relationship with but the reverse
isn't true and there is an argument that
the the aftershock of this means that
those women are going to constantly pine
after the nine out of ten guy that's
worth half a million and so all that
i
i'm
not sure about how long that would last
for and the echoes of that and stuff
like that but i certainly think that um
what porn has done to men which is to
teach them that women are to be
objectified is similar in part to what
only france has done to women which is
to teach some women that men are
commercial vehicles to be exploited and
that their sex is just a
it's a commodity you can trade it like
anything else
yeah and it's not i think as well
some women who already like posting a
lot of
raunchy photos on instagram don't
necessarily feel like any fans is that
biggest step it's just a bit more
explicit and you get paid for it so you
can sort of see
the reasoning and what some women say
and i
i get it is that you know yes maybe that
it means that some men in the future
wouldn't want to be in a relationship
with me because i've got these photos
out in the world but i wouldn't want to
be in a relationship with a man like
that anyway if he's going to judge me
sort of thing and the problem with that
is that if you actually look at research
on men it's like that's basically all
men they might not say it
because it's not really socially
acceptable to admit to
but actually is basically all men like
to the point that if a man isn't
bothered i'd wonder if he had a cuckold
fetish what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace